abone ol
[Müzik]
Selam merhabalar
ama başlangıçta benim tüm cumhuriyet
saçlarımı Aslında yerli bilirdi Çünkü
Çocukluğumda astım az sevdim ve Evden
bile dışarıya çıkamıyorum O dönemlerde
Doktorlar spor bile yapamayacağımı
söylemişti ve bir çocuk olarak gerçekten
Bunlar bunlardan dolayı muzdarip olmak o
dönemler için çok can sıkıcı çünkü evden
dışarıya çıkamıyorum arkadaşlarım
oynayamıyorum Hatta okula bile geç
başlamıştım ama çok şanslıyım ki bir
şekilde su sporları ile yolum kesişti
ilk dalış yaptığım günü hatırlıyorum ve
suyun altında adeta nefes aldığımı
hissettim o gün benim için hayat
gerçekten değişmişti şu an nefesimi altı
dakika tutabiliyorum 100 metre Derine
dala Biliyorum ve bu dönüşüm Aslında o
yerle bir olan domino taşlarını benim
için İlk defa dizmeye başlamak oldu
diyebilirim Alo sağlığına kavuştuktan
sonra tabi İnsanoğlu sürekli bir şeyler
yapmak istiyor kendini geliştirmek
istiyor Ben de okulumla birlikte Spora
devam ettim ama hedefin her zaman bu
konu kurabilmek Tea antrenmanlarda da
aslında biz dünya rekorunu üzerine çıka
biliyorduk fakat Tabi o yaşlarda ve o
yıllarda internet erişimi ile çok
kısıtlı olduğu yıllarda böyle şeyleri
Hayal etmenin ötesinde hayata geçirmek
gerçekten çok çok zordu ve benim hayalim
de mutlaka herhalde Mesleğimi yapmam
gerekecek başka bir dünya olduğunu
bilmiyordum ama en azından ben bir
klinik de diyetisyen olarak Mesleğimi
başlamadan önce hayalim olan şu dünya
rekorunu kırmaya çalışayım dedim ve bir
adım attım ilk dünya rekorunu öyle
sıradışı kıralım dedim ki bir daha
unutulmasın benim açımdan böyle yine tek
olarak kitabına girsin Çünkü bir daha
belki de kırma şansım olmayacaktı O
yüzden suyun altında Tek nefeste en uzun
mesafeyi kat etme buz altı rekor için
biz başvurular yaptıkta benim buzun
altında hiç dalmıştım yok bir Türk
sporcusu olarak biz bunun için çok küçük
imkânlarla Avusturya'ya gitti o ilk defa
hayatımda uzun altına girdim ve
gerçekten çok kasvetli yani buzun altı
yaklaşık 30 santim kalınlığında bir yüz
kesilerek içine giriyorsunuz Üzerinizde
bir ip çimento otoban yol var gibi
insanlar Üzerinizde yürüyebiliyor
araçlar geçebiliyor ve siz onun altında
o soğukta nefes tarak en uzun mesafeye
gitmeye çalışıyorsunuz benim burada
hedefim o kadınla rekoru olan 70 metreyi
değil erkekler rekoru olan 100 metreyi
geçerek Guinness Rekorlar Kitabı'na
girmek TV çalışmalara başladık Şimdi o
soğuk hissetmeye çalıştım adapte olmaya
çalıştım ve antrenmanlarda artık son
günlerde Biz 100 metre yapmaya başladık
fakat sonra enteresan şeyler oldu ama
önce bir izletmek istiyorum size rekor
denemesini güneyindeki size buz 6 tek
nefeste yine dünya rekorunu evsahipliği
yaptı Şahika Ercümen 6.30 kilometrekare
alanı ile Avrupa'nın en büyük doğal buz
pateni pisti olan gölde bir ilke imza
atmak için soğuk sulara girdik Yaklaşık
40 santimlik buzluğa açılan kare alandan
suya giren milli sporcunun hedefi 110
metre İlerideki ikinci açıklıktan
çıkmaktır bunu da Tek nefesle başarması
gerekiyordu buz 6 tek neresi rekor
erkeklerde 108 bayanlarda 70 metreydi
Şahika bu kategoride en uzağa giden
olmak için hedefiniz bu gibi olarak
belirledi Melis borcumuz Şahika Ercümen
buz altından serbest Sonuçta 110 metre
giderek Nez dünya rekorunu kırmak için
son hazırlıklarını yapıyor Şahika'nın
kılıca 110 metre hem bayanların hem de
erkeklerin Dünya rekorunun üzerinde Yani
bir ilk ve
beklenen an geldi Şahika buz gibi suda
buzun altından en uzağa giden olmak için
daldı Sualtı görüntü yönetmeni Tahsin
Ceylan Şahika'nın rekora gidişini an ve
an kaydetti
var mı
bu Şahika 110 ünitede iki dakika yirmi
saniye süren heyecanlı bekleyiş sonunda
rekoru uzandı
bu kategoride erkekler rekoru 108
bayanlar rekoru S70 metreydi
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
bu bizim rekor denememiz de tabi ben
size 100 metre dedim ama o gün gerçekten
rekor yüz metreydi fakat bizim rekor
denememiz den yaklaşık böyle bir 10 gün
önce Alman erkek bir dalgıç gelip bu
rekoru 108 metre ile kırdı ve Tabii
bizim bütün böyle planlar alaşağı oldu
Çünkü zaten çok zor imkânlarla
hazırlanmıştır ucu ucuna yaptığım bir
şeydi son günlerde bu kadar büyük bir
performans değişikliği fiziksel olarak
teorik olarak çok da mümkün değil
aslında Ama şunu da bana öğretmiş olduğu
isteyip inandıktan sonra her şey
gerçekten mümkün o gün biz çok inanarak
biz birbirimize kenetlenerek o rekoru
yüz olmasaydı kırdık ve Aslında benim
serüvenin böyle başladı diyebilirim bu
dönüm noktalarından bir tanesi Belki de
şu an aranızda olmayacaksın bırakır
olması ve bu rekor ve müthiş bir
başlangıç oldu benim için Yıllar İçinde
pek çok farklı deneme oldu değişik
kategorilerde Bununla birlikte Ben de
biraz özgüvenimi kazanıp işte Artık
ülkemizi temsil eden ben Bunu iş olarak
da yapabiliyorum diyebilecek bir konuma
geldim bu rekor denemesi zaman yaklaşık
birkaç sene sonra yine böyle hedefini
yükseğe diktim ve erkekler rekorunu yine
geçip bu sefer derinlik kategorisinde
Yani en derine Tek nefesle ve paletsiz
ilmek kategorisinde bir rekor denemesi
için bir sene boyunca çok yine hummalı
çalışmalara başladık O gerçekten biraz
da enteresan bir eko Çünkü Derine
daldıkça insanda çok fazla fizyolojik
değişim oluyor adet abi Yunus bir balina
gibi fizz bu değişimler gözlemlenir
vücudunuzda Örneğin ben 100 metre
indiğimde akciğerlerin bir futbol topu
kadarken şu an suyun altında bir Tenis
topu kadar küçülebilir your damarlarınız
daralıyor kalbinizin aldığınız
yavaşlıyor ve yaklaşık 30'lara
inebiliyor nabzım suyun altında bunları
adapte olmak için de aylarca çalışmamız
gerekiyor ve o gün rekor denemesinde
antrenmanlarda yaptığımız için bir de
işte önce kırdığımız bu rekorlarında
etkisiyle Aslında yine güvenim tamdı ama
tabii o rekor Bundaki gibi böyle
etrafına ne kadar insanlar görünse de
orada yüzlerce insan vardı onlarca canlı
yayın vardı sponsorlar vardı falan ve
çok heyecanlı bir ortamda gerçekten
bizim için de en önemli şey en zor
koşullarda bile çok sakin ve Nabzın
düşük olması Tatvan biraz heyecanlandım
böyle tam da aslında film senaryosu
gibiydi kasvetli bir hava yağmur başladı
falan böyle dekor öncesinde ama bir
şekilde o dalışa başladım Her şey
yolunda giderken yüz metreyi indim ama
çıkışta artık nefesim çok iyi
ayarlayamadım fazla oksijen tükettim
suyun altında ya Yani yaptığımız böyle
analizlere göre çıkışta son olmayacağı
da bir baygınlık geçirdim da bir canlı
yayınlarda verdiği var ya Biz normalde
bu branşı yapan insanlardan rekor
derecesinde bu sporu yapıyorsanız
bayılma ihtimaliniz var ama bunlar
Hayati bayılmalar değil yani başınızın
dönüp şöyle bir gözünüzün kararması gibi
bayılmalar fakat Tabi bu konuyla ilgili
insanlar bilmediği için ekranda beni
görenler başıma çok kötü en kötü şeyin
geldiğini düşündüler ve o anda canlı
yayın kesilince be çok enteresan bir
şeye döndü psikolojik olarak ben çok
yıprandım çıkışta ve O gün gerçekten
enkaz gibiydim Çünkü bir sene Sadece üç
dakikalık dalış için çalıştım ve tüm
canlı yayınlarını önünde o kadar
yüzlerce insanın önünde yere kuru
Başaramadım aslında bu fakat sonra
gördüm ki aslında hiç böyle başarısızlık
gibi değil tam tersi ben rekor kırdım da
bir şey öğreniyordum bu rekoru kıramadık
Tan sonra gerçekten onun on katını
öğrendiğimi gördüm muazzam bir deneyim
olduğunu gördüm ve Aslında belki de biz
birşeyleri çizmeye çalışıyoruz ya bir
resim var Kafamızda Bazen sadece önümüzü
görüyoruz O taşları bir şekilde çizmeye
çalışıyoruz ama bazen de bizim O
istediğimiz şekilde olmayan doğrultuda
bambaşka yerlere o Taşlarda alabiliyor
ve geniş olarak büyük resme baktığımızda
Hiç de kötü olmadığını görebiliyoruz O
yüzden o dar bakış açısından bir
uzaklaşıp tepeden baktığımda ve bir süre
sonra baktığımda benim için çok daha iyi
bir yolun açıldığını başarısızlıkla
yüzleştiği mi hayatta inişler çıkışlar
olduğunu ve benim hayallerimden de öte
bazen Benim planlarım dan da öte çok
güzel şeylerin olabileceğine hayata
güvenmeye başladım inanmaya başladım o
şu an galiba o mahvoldu her şeyi yıkıldı
gibi gördüğümüz şeyler de o domino
taşları da bazen Bizim isteğimiz
doğrultusunda değil kendi yollarını
bulduklarında da çok güzel yerlere
gidebiliyorlar şimdi Tabi ben sağlığımız
sporla kavuştum dua ile kavuştum suyla
kavuştum O yüzden ilk günden itibaren
suya minnettarım her zaman suya Deniz
canlılarına denize okyanusa Çünkü
biliyorsunuz şu an aldığımız havayı bile
yüzde yetmişini okyanuslar denizler
temizliyor ve bunun için her rekor
denememde ben ne yapabilirim diye
düşündüğümde denizlerimiz için bir
projeyi öncelik vermeye çalıştım bunun
en büyük sebebi Aslında suya girdiği ilk
yılından itibaren doğanın değişimi çok
iyi gözlemleyebilir yorum şu an yüzeyde
gördüğünüz çöpler Deniz çöpleri atıklar
maalesef sadece yüzde 15'ini oluşturuyor
denize çöplerin Bunların çoğu yüzde
sekseni ve üzeri suyun altında ve ben de
onları maalesef sürekli gözlemliyorum
var bunun dışında çok sevdiğimiz Sualtı
camları Caretta carettalar Balinalar
bazen dalış yaparken mi karette karette
yanıma geliyor ve boynuna poşet dolanmış
veya üzerine bira dolanmış şekilde onu
olan kurtarmaya çalışıyoruz kendine
getirmeye çalışıyoruz plastik atıklarla
dolu dalışlar yapıyoruz ve bazen
Maalesef o caretta caretta İyi kurt
aramıyoruz veya bir balinanın karnından
40 kilogram plastik atık çıktığını ve
onun Can çekişerek öldüğünü
gözlemliyoruz Bu dalışlar benim pandemi
sonrası İstanbul Boğazı'nda yaptığımda
dışlar Burada çok fazla Maske ve eldiven
asıyla karşılaştık
dolayısıyla bunları gözlemlemek çok can
açık acıtıcı ama bunlar için mutlaka bir
şey yapmamız gerektiğini her zaman
biliyordum ve özellikle geçtiğimiz
seneden itibaren birleşmiş milletlerle
ortak projeler yapıyoruz Ben de
Birleşmiş Milletler'in Sudaki yaşam
savunucusu yum bu konu En az benim
Rekorlar kadar önemsediği O ne oldu
çünkü biz ekosistemde her şey aslında
biriyle o kadar bağlantılı ki bugün
attığımız şu plastik çöpler balığın
karnına gidiyor ya ondan sonra tekrar
bizim sofralarımıza yemek olarak geliyor
Veya siz hiçbir şey tüketmiyor sanız
bile en güvenilir kaynaklardan you sanız
bile soluduğunuz havayla o
denizlerimizden filtrelendi için havamız
bize yine havadan hiç artık bizim onu
yani filtreli yemeyeceksiniz şekilde
mikroplastikler vücudumuza ulaşabiliyor
Örneğin antartikada yaptığım bir dalış
var orada yapılan bir araştırma
gerçekten çok çarpıcı hiç insan
yaşamayan bir kıtadan bahsediyoruz biz
oraya beş günde ulaştık Türkiye'den
bilim ekibi ile gitmiştik Ben de su
altından örnekler almıştım ve oraya
gittiğimizde yapılan araştırmalarda
mikroplastikler asıldığı görüldü demek
oluyor ki bizim bugün burada attığımız
bir çöp antartika'ya gidip orada
mikroplastik olarak denizlere
yapılabiliyor de aynı şey oradan bize de
gelebiliyor O yüzden bu döngünün içinde
Yaptığımız her annenin bir etkisi var
aslında ve ben artık
bu domino taşlarını sadece lineer bir
çizgide ilerleme dini fark etmeye
başladım doğa ile iç içe olduktan sonra
Çünkü doğal çok öğretici çok daha geniş
bir
perspektiften bakmamızı sağlıyor
biraz sadece cesaret gerektiğini
düşünüyorum bazen çünkü biz genelde ilk
olmak bir korkutur bilmediğimiz
bilinmezlikle yüzleşmek hep korkutur Ya
da ben mi kurtaracağım dünyayı deriz
Evet biz kurtaracağız yani kurtaracak
başka gerçekten kimse yok ve onu Bugün
yapmamız lazım Çünkü biz bunu
değiştirebilecek gerçekten son meslis
başka emanet edebileceğimiz bekleye
bileceğimiz hiçbir şey yok artık her yer
kırmızı alarm veriyor O yüzden ben de
bunu göremediniz Sualtı ile ilgili
denizlerin kurulması ile ilgili çalış O
çok aktif yer almaya çalışıyorum bazen
Hani o süreci başlatmak çok zor olsa da
ilk olmaya çalışıyorum ilham verebilmek
için
köpekbalıklarıyla dalıp onların Aslında
Cami değil de insanların her sene
yüzbinlerce köpekbalığını katletmeye
çalıştığını göstermeye çalışıyorum
veya antartikada gidip orada lan İlk
Türk kadını olup ne olacak böyle olunca
Sadece küçük bir ilham verebilmek
dünyada uluslararası platformda
ismimizin geçmesi için çabalamak
diyebilirim bu gilindire mağarası da
yaptığımız ilk dalış orada yapılan ilk
savaş Daha doğrusu ve
ve günün sonunda baktığımda ekosistemin
bu kadar kendi içinde güzel bir düzeni
varken dengesi varken bizim yaptığımız
her hamlenin her hareketin tüm dünyayı
etkilediğini görüyorum ve o hep başından
beri bahsettiğimiz birbirini tetikleyen
olaylar domino taşları Bu benim için şu
an baktığımda Aslında domino dan da öte
bir kelebek etkisi yaratıyor bugün
yaptığımız bir şey dünyanın öbür ucuna
ulaşabiliyor sa bugün hareketlerimiz
dende 10 sene sonra da sorumluyuz
Dolayısıyla ben domino etkisiyle
başlayıp kelebek etkisi ne dönen bir
süreci yaşadım Çok teşekkürler